[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know let's bring in frank isola he'd
be the guy to talk to when it comes to
music like this frank you uh you want to
add anything to this
i figured it was the natural segway
we're talking hip-hop so why not
why not bring me on i like all those
guys that you mentioned i'm like you dan
i know the songs i just don't know who
played them
i went to a youtube concert years ago
i flew out to portland it was going to
be the final night of their u.s tour
it was like three days before christmas
my wife's still not talking to me about
this
because i went and kanye west was the
warm-up act
and we got out there and we were
probably like we were standing up
we were like three people from the stage
he was
unbelievable he was so good he played
for about 90 minutes he was great
and you two put him up there too you two
has always been great um i saw them when
uh they had
uh muse opened up for them yes and uh
kings of leon opened up for them i saw
that one too yeah yeah and i saw them
with damian marley once
you know like the reggae yeah he was
outstanding really good
all right frank well that was it we
appreciate you uh i'll see you guys
um woads just reported that the bulls
landed uh nicola vucevic
uh a couple other players for otto
porter wendell carter jr and two
first-round picks here
and the chicago's still in the chase for
lonzo ball
why is it that other teams want lonzo
ball but new orleans doesn't want lonzo
ball
i think it's because they're going to
eventually have to pay lonzo ball but
there is a lot of interest in him and
you think about he's
he's improved a lot i think his shot has
improved a lot
he's a big time athlete he's not going
to be better than his brother but his
brother has a chance to be a perennial
all-star i kind of like that deal though
for chicago vucevic
there was a good stat that somebody just
had there were four guys in the nba this
year averaging at least 24 points
and 10 rebounds nicole yokic giannis
joel embiid all three of those guys are
mvp candidates now you have vucevic
who's putting up those numbers on a
losing team i get that
but you put him with zach levine and
obviously the bulls aren't done i think
this is a team that's headed in the
right direction with that new management
team and obviously with billy donovan as
a head coach
let me go back to new orleans and the
pelicans when i watch
they're they're a below average team
frank i know like i don't underst
what is missing here i don't understand
this well for one
they don't play enough defense and i
think zion williamson has been terrific
but on the defensive end he's not good
and you know we just mentioned lamela
ball
but one thing that sticks out for me the
most about lamella ball
is he got to charlotte he's putting up
good numbers and the team has been
winning now i get it he's in the eastern
conference so it's a little bit
different
to me that's still going to be the
measure and the impact that you're
really going to have on a team
and maybe there still needs to be some
growth that has to happen there because
it is a very young team and it's
probably going to
it's not going to get older anytime soon
and they're just trying to navigate
their way through the western conference
the west is tough
i think a lot of people are disappointed
i think they should be a little bit
further along
but defense is the problem with that
team they just don't guard anybody are
the clippers
interested in lonzo ball like what's the
likely where's his landing
spot well i think there's a uh you know
a few teams
i think the knicks believe it or not are
still interested in him i think if he
went to a team like the clippers
i think he could help them the problem
with the clippers is they would love to
have a guy like kyle lowry
but i just don't think they have enough
to give the clippers back
not only just in terms of assets because
remember they made those trades to get
paul george they gave up all their first
round picks
but i don't even think they have enough
to give back in terms of contracts
so to me kylari the perfect fit for him
would be the clippers you put him there
that's what they need
a leader a guy that's been through it
before
a tough guy he take he's flopping all
over the court he knows how to draw
fouls
that would be the perfect player lonzo
ball could help them but does it take
them
over the lakers if if lebron and anthony
davis comes back i'm not sure about that
what about kyle lowry to the lakers do
they have
the pieces that's that would be a big
time move for them and that's the thing
when you when you have lebron on your
team and who knows he'll probably play
until he's 50.
but you know you have to look at it like
you're you have a golden opportunity
right now and if they can get him
that would be some move i think kyle
from what i had heard uh the last couple
of days from
a guy that's close with kyle lowry is
that you know he really if he's not
going to stay in toronto he'd like to go
to miami
i think that's something that appeals to
him but i think the lakers have always
been out there and he fits in so
perfectly
with that team in terms of his toughness
and his leadership could knock down a
three-point shot anybody that plays with
lebron
is going to be that much better and you
put kyle larry and anthony davis there
come on that's a pretty formidable team
aaron gordon once out of orlando where
do you think he ends up
yeah dan there was a great story she
looked up the quotes from aaron gordon
he said that he had a meeting with
management he expressed frustration with
the losing
and the way that the team has been
playing yes that's why they paid you the
money
so you're the one that's supposed to do
something about the losing imagine how
frustrated management must be
that they're paying you all this money i
mean that's some meaning to have you
know
that's that i got a kick out of that you
know the problem with a lot of these
players
you know can they be the third best
player on a championship level team
that's to me what you're looking at i
don't think aaron gordon could be your
second best player and you could be a
championship
team yeah anthony davis with lebron
absolutely anthony davis when he was in
new orleans got out of the first round
just one time so aaron gordon
i would think the ceiling for him is the
third best player in the championship
team and i'm not so sure where that fits
right now
frank isola joining us uh net studio
host on yes uh
he's got the nba radio the starting
lineup and uh
you can see him on around the horn and
pardon the interruption
are the clippers a contender like it
feels like we don't talk about them the
way we did
say a year ago yeah i think you're right
and the way that everything ended in the
bubble for them it's
nobody's going to take them seriously
until we see them as an organization
finally get to a conference final which
is something they've never done before
so paul george is playing well and
everyone's saying
talk to me come play off time and then
the guy that kind of you know
got off scot-free a little bit here is
kawhi leonard
he was the one that came in and had to
move heaven and earth to bring in paul
george
and listen he did play well against
denver he didn't have a great game seven
but i don't know if that's lebron james
and he doesn't have a great game seven
we'll
we're still talking about it today so um
you have to put a lot on kauai and
here's a crazy thing dan
he could be a free agent he could leave
can you imagine everything they did to
get kawhi leonard and everything he
wanted them to do
and then come the offseason whatever
that is this year maybe in august he
tells him i'll see you later i'm going
someplace else
where does that lawsuit stand with the
guy who said he helped
facilitate kawhi to the clippers with
jerry west
yeah i mean i can't imagine it's it's
gonna go very far
was jerry west probably speaking to
somebody who's close friends
with kawhi leonard absolutely but did
this person have anything to do with
kawhi going there
i highly doubt that dan people were
talking about this
all throughout the season in toronto i
thought that toronto was going to be
able to resign him
not only when they went to the finals
but when they won a championship i
figured you know what maybe he'll stay
one or two years then he'll go
out to the western conference but
everyone was saying clippers or lakers
all throughout the year so how much did
this person have to do with it just
because you had a couple of
conversations with jerry west i'm not
buying that
what about the nets uh with what they're
doing well james harden is doing
uh with kyrie out durant's still out
uh do they do anything at the trade
deadline well they could be a team in
the buyout market there's been talk
about maybe jj redick
you know javale mcgee now was off the
board he got traded andre drummond is
still out there
the one thing about brooklyn if you look
at james harden what he has done so last
night
they held him out of the game and steve
nash after the win against washington
the other night and hardin took a knock
to the head he looked like he was out of
it
his neck was hurting he started the
second half i was surprised that he
played in that game
he played against portland but nash had
said i'm concerned about the minutes i
don't know what to do about it
i think they held him out of the game
last night he was in uniform
to me that's a player's way of saying
they're holding me out
he didn't feel like he needed to get
dressed up and wear some crazy outfit
that he's putting on a fashion show on
the bench to me he wanted to be out
there
he's carried the team kevin durant is
their best player the face of the team
right now is james hard
you know that he's played 30 games kevin
durant in his next career
has played 19. kyrie's only played 31.
this guy
missed the first 13 games of the season
with the nets and he's and he's going to
end up playing more games than both
kevin durant
and kyrie irving but do you think it's
harden's team
i i do from this standpoint he's been
the one
carrying them now when they get kevin
durant and this is the thing about the
trade deadline today
everyone's going to be trying to make
moves we're assuming the nets are going
to get kevin durant back they're saying
it's only a hamstring
injury and i think now they're just
being extra cautious nobody
is acquiring a player like the nets are
going to get back
in kevin durant and kevin durant is
invested from this standpoint
he knows there's one result that he can
get you either win
or it's been a bust doesn't mean you
can't go back next year and try to win
it
there's a lot of pressure on them he is
so happy with the way that hardin has
played and harden is the same way
harden forced his way out of houston he
knows what his reputation was
he knows there's only one satisfactory
result and that's winning that's why
this team has been all in
charles barkley uh said recently that
harden's best player in the game and
talked about you know just what he does
offensively it's
unlike anybody else which i look i agree
with the offensive side of this i don't
think he's the best player in the game
but
he's on the short list there um he could
have played back in the
80s or 90s with the physicality there
i'm just curious what
jordan and kobe some of these players
now kobe had a little bit of this era
but
yeah you know spread spread the floor
can't put your hands on anybody
they would have developed into better
three-point shooters because
your offense almost calls for that i
said earlier
i think that uh you know mike and kobe
averaged at least 40 a game
at the peak of their careers in today's
nba they averaged
high 30s you know back in another era
what do you think you know when you we'd
love to compare arrows there but if i
put jordan and some of these other
players in today's game
how much does their game change evolve
and what do you think they average
well you were living through it uh when
michael jordan was going was playing and
you remember doc rivers about what six
foot five derek harper six foot three
both strong and they're both putting
their hand
right on michael jordan's hip and trying
to guide them to where they want to take
him
you're allowed to be really physical
with him and he still is leading the
league in scoring and he's winning
championships can you imagine him
in today's nba with how many times they
call
fouls he'd he would spend the entire
game at the free-throw line see for me
it's a little bit different
and i'm sure you the same way i think
michael jordan's the best player of all
time i just
i never felt you were going to beat him
four times in a playoff series
so i think if you put him in today's nba
if he wanted to and he had the same
drive that he had back then because
today with load management who knows how
he would be
if but if he was willing to play 80
games a year 80 to
going to average 30 to 35 points and
he's going to win mvp every year
yeah i remember phil jackson came in he
was promoting his book
and i said what would mike average now
and he said he could see him average
40 45 points again but that's if your
coach
if if michael was playing for the
rockets
where d'antoni was his coach then mike
could average whatever he wanted average
because that's what james was allowed to
do
yeah you're 100 right and i think ever
since hardin got to brooklyn if you look
the other night he had 17 assists
he's the when he grabs a rebound much
like lebron his head is up and he's
looking to throw the ball
ahead so i get it in houston they wanted
him to play a certain way and all he did
was dribble the ball for basically 22
seconds on the shot clock
then he would take the step back three
but he's been an unbelievable leader on
this team he's always looking to get
guys involved in late in games
when he feels like he has to take over
he puts his head down
he drives to the basket and he makes
that floater and if the defense
commits he flows he throws the ball up
for an alley you it's amazing
how he reads the game he's he he sees
the plays develop like a split second
before
everybody else it's the mark really of a
brilliant player and it's the one thing
that is
probably not highlighted with harden
because we look at him as a gunner a
volume shooter
his ability to and you you say this
keep his head up and see the floor and
see a play before it develops
that's rarely highlighted with james
harden
yeah and and i think too if you look at
mike d'antoni he had
in phoenix steve nash a two-time mvp in
the league and i think nash was the same
obviously the same way the difference is
that harden at any point could just
dominate a game scoring that's what
makes him so tough so if they get kevin
durant back
and kyrie irving is going to be around
and he's going to play in every game
it's going to be so difficult for any
team in the eastern conference to beat
them
now milwaukee with pj tucker now the
true holidays back look the way that
they've played i think it's now eight in
a row
so they'll be a tough team uh
philadelphia's done really well with
that embiid and beat has dominated the
nets a couple of times this season
so they'll present challenges but if and
i understand it's a seven foot
you know if that's kevin durant in his
health but if he's healthy i just don't
know how you can beat that team because
with durant
and car durant and hard and they're
unstoppable then you throw kyrie into
the mix who by the way
has played really well the last three
weeks he's just not with the team now
the last couple of games i'll leave you
with this if the bucks had won the
championship last year
would the mvp voters be looking at the
greek freak differently
uh and and maybe a three-peat it almost
looks like it's being held against him
yeah i i think you're right i always say
that too about the voting you know the
media votes for it
and we all kind of like a story it was
like carl malone winning that one year
when you probably could have given it to
michael jordan like you could give it to
michael jordan every year you can kind
of give it to lebron
but remember though we did vote based on
the season ending i think it was march
11th or march 12th whenever it was last
year and at that point giannis had done
more the team had the best record in the
league
from the bubble on lebron was the best
player so lebron was bringing up an
argument which really didn't hold water
we had voted
in march but i do think you're right and
i think sometimes there's a little voter
fatigue
with an mvp that's why maybe this could
be the year for a guy like damien
lillard
maybe nicole jokic james harden said
that's the thing too the media might be
thinking ah the way that you handled
your exit
and you said i don't like it either but
come on now the guy is certainly an mvp
candidate but with embiid out right now
and lebron out
it's kind of wide open and the honest
certainly is making a move right now
is that lynn bias's jersey behind you
yes
the great lin bias what what's the
reason behind it i went
i went to maryland yeah i was a freshman
with his last year what a senior year he
had they went down to carolina
carolina had never lost they were number
one in the country they had never lost a
game yet in the dean dome
right yeah and that's when len bias went
down that was that great play where he
has
he hits the three then he steals the
inbound from kenny smith
and dunks the ball backward i mean come
on now that's a pretty good college
house how would you describe him for
those who didn't see len bias
well i think if you ask michael jordan
he would i i'm not going to say he's on
michael jordan's level but if he had
played for the boston celtics when that
group
still had a lot left i don't think it's
much of a reach to say that he would
have been
uh that they would want another
championship he went to duke senior so
his senior they beat number one
caroline and carolina where you know
they get every single call dean smith
standing up the whole time complaining
about traveling they went down to duke
and i i think he had 40 or 41
and the duke students were balancing
they were doing this
so like people knew that len bias was a
different kind of player yeah
frank uh thanks for joining us enjoy the
day and we appreciate you uh spending
time with us
thanks dan good seeing you that's uh
frank isola he is a studio host with the
nets and also uh part of
siriusxm nba radio the starting lineup
around the horn and pardon the
interruption